think about the match in my opinion it's
difficult - it will be probably more
interesting than the games I I believe
they will be more interesting than the
match Carlson against Kuryakin but at
the same time it's difficult to say who
is the big I don't think it's it's quite
level except if they reach a tie-break
and then I I could see an advantage for
Magnus
I feel think Magnus is the favorite just
because he has that level of experience
but and anything can can happen I think
one small lack of attention and one
small lack of focus and distraction from
from Magnus can be all the difference he
came very close to qualifying in 16 and
I felt that he wouldn't have been a bad
bad Challenger in 16 I feel grown and
improved since and also I think
stylistically
[Music]
he is a very interesting Challenger for
Magnus because I think this much will be
very very unlike the previous one in
terms of the way the challenger
approaches trying to women because sir
gays approach was very much containment
I think it's extremely unlikely
Ljubljana will be doing any anything of
the sort I think it will be much more
open open contest with people going at
each other a lot harder
I think people people are very very
excited for for the photo match and it
should be very interesting spectacle
well it will be very difficult first of
all because mangas plays also very good
in a rapid chess and so he will not be
afraid of dialects and and Fabiano is
more focused on a classical chasms and
in rapist also I can say that I can sail
some secret to Fabiana with discount
[Laughter]